Zinc gutters drain rainwater and in the
process develop a natural resistance to
corrosion. When zinc is exposed to wet and
dry cycles, a chemical reaction occurs,
forming a protective patina on its surface.
No paint or special treatment needed.
You can't stop the rain, but you can stop it
from damaging buildings and their
foundations. These U shaped zinc gutters
funnel water away from the structures to keep
them dry. The process starts with the
production of these 46 ton coils of zinc.
The zinc arrives at the factory in the form
of thick plates.
These plates are almost 100% zinc.
The plates drop into a furnace.
Inside, the temperature reaches 750°F.
Workers add a bit of copper and titanium to
reinforce the zinc, and it melts into a
homogeneous liquid.
The molten zinc then flows into a trough
style conveyor system.
Residues like ashes float to the top of the
metal soup, and a worker skims them off.
A floating puck monitors the speed and depth
of the zinc blende to prevent overflow.
The molten zinc now arrives at the casting
machine.
Here, three foot wide steel unwinds and once
linear, the zinc flows onto it.
The steel acts as a mould to form the zinc
into a long rigid sheet.
Water flows onto the zinc to accelerate
cooling and solidification.
Since water and liquid zinc don't mix, the
water simply runs off the surface.
Now solid, the zinc plate is almost a third
of an inch thick, far too thick for making
lightweight rain gutters.
The next operation will thin the plate down
dramatically.
This is a powerful rolling mill.
The pressure on its rollers is so great that
they often must be replaced.
Once the new rollers have been loaded, the
mill heats them up.
The operator activates the rollers as they
revolve.
The hot rollers exert 770 tons of pressure
to iron the zinc much thinner.
Meanwhile, just ahead, a steel belt
tensioning system swings into action.
This system prevents slackening in the zinc
sheet as it exits the rolling mill and moves
forward. You can see the difference the
rolling has made.
It has reduced the thickness of the zinc
sheet to about three quarters of a
millimeter. The steel belt system maintains
the tension in the zinc sheet as it's wound
around a core.
This produces the 46 ton coil of zinc.
It's known as the mother coil.
Approximately 25 miles of rain gutters can
be made from this coil.
Workers slit the mother coil into three.
Each coil is a foot wide.
It is now the correct width to be formed
into rain gutters.
A crane lifts one of the narrower coils over
the factory floor.
Its journey is guided by the operator below.
This puts it in position to be mounted to
the next machine, one that will cut it into
uniform 13 foot long strips.
That's the standard length for the rain
gutters.
As the zinc uncoils, an overhead mirror
provides a top view for the operator.
In quick swoops.
The blade slices the zinc sheeting to the
correct length.
The zinc strips then travel through a
progressively narrow channel and over a
cylinder. This rounds the profile.
More rollers, improve on the U-shape and
also curl the edges of the gutters to
reinforce them.
This gives the zinc rain gutters their final
shape.
The automated profiler ejects the 13 foot
long gutters onto a rounded rack.
Then it tips to stack the gutters neatly on
top of each other.
The zinc rain gutters are ready to hang.
On site, they'll be welded together and
attach to the roof with special hooks.
They should come in handy on a rainy day.
The French Basque Country is culturally
quite distinct from the rest of France.
Located in the southwest bordering Spain,
the region is known, among other things, for
its ham, which is salted and air cured in an
old tradition passed down through generations
of Basque farmers.
There are several types of traditional
Basque ham.
This one, called quinoa, is marbled with fat
and has a deep, strong, fruity flavor.
Its distinct taste and composition begin
with a specific breed of pig.
The Basque Country piebald refers to the
animal's skin.
This pig breed is native to the Basque
region, where livestock are raised on small
farms in the valleys of the Pyrenees
mountains.
Unlike commercially farmed animals, the
female pigs have small litters of 6 to 9
piglets which grow up roaming and grazing
along the vast mountainsides.
On an average of two acres of land per 30
piglets.
As a result of this free range rearing, the
pigs grow more slowly and become heavier than
commercially farmed pigs.
Once the animals reach a weight of about
£330, which usually takes a year to 15
months, they go to the slaughterhouse.
Each carcass is stamped with an
identification number.
Traditional ham is made from the hind legs.
After tagging the leg, a worker places it in
a machine which brands the canto a symbol
into the flesh.
Then another worker spreads dry salt on the
exposed portion.
The salt comes from Sayda debayan, a
saltwater spring in a basin bordered by the
Pyrenees Mountains.
Theodora River and the Atlantic Ocean.
Workers leave the salted ham in a cold, damp
room for one day per every £2, typically
about 15 days per ham.
The salt preserves the meat.
Next, the ham undergoes a first dry curing.
It hangs on a stainless steel rack in a
temperature and humidity controlled room for
seven months.
When the ham comes out of the room, it has
lost about 20% of its original weight because
most of the moisture has evaporated.
A worker brushes off the surface.
And coats the exposed part of the ham with a
special grease that's made out of pigs
kidneys, rice flour and water.
This grease prevents the surface from drying
out and crusting during the second dry
curing. The ham now goes into a second
drying room, which dries the ham in the open
air. Taking advantage of this particular
geographic location, a warm southern wind
from Spain and humid air from the Atlantic
Ocean to the west blow into the room through
windows. Nature does all the work.
Humans merely regulate the airflow and
humidity by lifting or lowering the blinds.
In this room, the ham hangs from a wooden
rather than stainless steel rack.
That's because the wood absorbs excess
humidity and transfers moisture to the meat
if the air gets too dry.
As the ham dries, its flavor concentrates
the Charcutier, an artisanal pork butcher,
inspects every ham carefully.
The wind that dries.
The ham carries pollen and other natural
particles, which give this ham a distinct
flavor and fragrance.
The secret is slow curing until the ham
reaches optimal maturity.
That takes approximately one month per £2,
so the ham remains in the second drying room
for more than a year.
When the cured ham is ready, workers
sprinkle it with espelette pepper, a mildly
hot pepper from the northern Basque Country.
This gives the ham a fragrance that's as
appetizing as its taste.